>>Vic Gundotra: Now, as Android adoption has
skyrocketed, people have been taking these
devices to work.
And we've heard loud and clear from the enterprise
that they need very specific features.
Well, in Froyo, we introduce over 20 new features
designed to meet the needs of enterprise.
Let me touch on two of them.
Number one, we become Microsoft exchange friendly.
That means --
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Yes, thank you.
That means things like auto-discovery, integration
with the global address book, the security
policies that are available in Exchange can
be forced upon the device.
Number two, we've added new APIs for device
management.
So you can build software that does critically
important things, like remote wipe of the
device if necessary.
And there's many, many other things that we've
added that you'll see in the documentation.
Let's talk about new services available for
developers in the SDK.
Now, one of the first services I want to talk
about is the application data backup API.
Now, if you use Android and you've gone to
another device, you know that Android will
automatically back up your applications.
In other words, you get a new device, you
log in, and your applications come along with
that.
However, what Android has not done is backed
up the data associated with those applications.
So, for example, I have a particularly favorite
application that helps me monitor my exercise
and my weight.
But when I move to a new Android device, the
application moves, but all my personal data
and history doesn't.
Starting with Froyo, we'll provide an application
data backup API that ISVs can take advantage
of and move the data along with the application.
We think that's a great feature.
In addition to that, we have a brand-new API,
a cloud-to-device messaging API.
Let me be clear, this is not a push notification
API designed to compensate for the lack of
basic functionality like multitasking in the
operating system.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Okay?
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: We've done something very
clever I think you're going to love.
As a developer, you can send a message to
our servers which will do very smart things,
like collapse similar messages, our servers,
which will optimize for the latency of mobile
networks and make sure that that message gets
down to the device.
But that's only the first step.
We've done deep integration with Android such
that when you send a message, that message
can trigger an Android intent.
Let me show you how powerful this is.
Let's go to a demo.
Now, what Matt has on the screen here on his
laptop is Google Maps.
He's -- in Google Maps -- and he's using the
Chrome browser.
And he's added a Chrome extension.
The Chrome extension is in the upper right-hand
corner.
That sends it to his phone.
In the map, he has directions, he has directions
from the Moscone Center to Google headquarters.
And he wants to send that to the phone.
What do you think happens?
Do you think we send a text message that says,
"This is the address"?
Do you think we send an e-mail?
No.
We send Android intent.
In other words, when he says send to phone,
the message gets sent to our server, gets
pushed down to the device.
The device kicks into navigation mode automatically.
Keep your eye when he clicks on "send to phone,"
keep your eye on the Android device.
So send it to phone.
And on the Android device, boom, right into
navigation.
How hot is that?
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: That's how you do a device,
cloud-to-device API.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Let me show you another example.
You're reading an article on the desktop.
You think it's awesome, but you're out of
time and you need to run.
You want to keep reading that on the Android
phone.
Why don't you send that to the device, Matt.
To the device.
Opens up the browser, takes you right to that
article, not ever having to press any other
keys.
Isn't that great?
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: We can't wait to see what
you're going to go do with this API.
All right.
Let's go back to slides.
You're going to love this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: I mean, come on.
If you're like me, you have a plethora of
devices you carry around with you.
And that -- all those devices shouldn't mean
added complexity and yet another bill.
Right?
You should be able to, at the platform level,
enable tethering.
And so now your Android device can in fact
become a portable hot spot and really serve
the needs of these other devices that you
might have with you.
In fact, let's show you a demo of this working.
Matt has a Nexus One running Froyo.
He'll go right into tethering and portable
hot spot.
He'll enable the hot spot.
He'll give it a name.
In fact, I think he's already named this as
Android AP.
And that hot spot will turn on.
We'll give it a second there.
There we go.
Tethering hot spot is now active.
Now he'll go to another device that doesn't
have connectivity.
How about that iPad?
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: And there you go.
One bill.
Isn't that beautiful?
All right.
Let's go back to slides.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Now, it turns out, do you
know what the most popular thing people do
with these smartphones?
What do you think it is?
It's fairly obvious.
Is they actually use the phone.
Number two thing they do is, they do text
messaging.
And the third most-used application is the
browser.
And so it's critically important for us to
make the Android browser rock.
And we're going to constantly improve that
browser.
And Froyo is a major step in that direction.
What have we done in Froyo?
Well, I think you're going to love this.
We have a two to three X performance in the
browser?
How?
We took the same JavaScript interpreter that
we had in Chrome that made Chrome so fast,
V8, and we brought that into Froyo.
Now, the best way to show you how much of
an advance we've made is to do a demo.
So let's go and show you this fantastic performance
boost.
Now, we're going to do this demo with a number
of devices.
We're going to do it --
>>> Two devices.
>>Vic Gundotra: We're going to do this demo
-- three devices.
We're going to do this demo with Froyo, Eclair,
and an iPad.
Now, here's the demo we're going to do.
There's an industry-standard test, in fact,
there's -- it's a suite of 26 tests, the SunSpider
test, that really exercise JavaScript performance
of all kinds.
And when Matt presses "start" across these
three devices, we're going to exercise each
one of these 26 tests.
As we complete one test, that little Android
robot will take one breast stroke forward.
And as all 26 tests are complete, we're going
to complete an entire lap.
How are we going to go do here?
Let's go ahead and start this test.
Let's what happens.
Oh, you started the iPad first, trying to
give it a little bit of a lead here, huh?
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: You can cheer.
It's great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: I really wonder if we'll be
able to get that in the app store.
It's a Web app, how great is that?
All right.
Let's go back to slides.
We think with the performance improvements
that we just showed you that we can claim
that Froyo has the world's fastest mobile
browser. And that's a pretty great accomplishment,
one we are extremely proud of. We're not done.
I showed you what's in Froyo, but make no
mistake about our commitment to maintain leadership
in the browser on Android. And one of the
ways we are doing that is to have standards
bodies to enable Web developers to get capabilities
that were formerly only limited to the native
access to the platform.
What kind of capabilities? Think about the
kinds of things you can access on a device,
things like the magnetometer, the accelerometer.
Think about things like the camera or being
able to access speech. Wouldn't this be great
if you could access this from the browser.
We are going to show you a sneak peek at something
beyond Froyo, an early development build that
will give you a flavor of where we're going
next.
Let's go back to demos.
Now, remember, we already got some of this
work under way. Last year we worked with the
standards committees to introduce geo location
into the browser, and today almost in all
major modern platforms, you can make an API
call from the browser, get location with the
user's permission, and then do a feature like
My Location right within the browser.
But we want to do more. How about the accelerometer.
What about access to tilt in the direction
of the device?
Watch this.
Isn't that great? Right within the browser.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: All right.